bonsoir gérald olivier merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on a
entendu un autre reporter thomas parler
voilà de ses propos
pardon de fraude n'est pas de preuves on
lui dira les deux mais enfin c'est
justement pas la même chose de fraudes
massives sans apporter de preuves
quelles sont les chances justement pour
que donald reproche de n'être homme
apporte ses preuves selon vous en fait
ils ont des preuves le problème c'est
qu'elle ne porte pas sur un une quantité
de bulletins probablement suffisante
pour permettre de renverser la donne
très concrètement qu'est-ce qui se passe
les républicains sont en train de
contester le décompte en dans le
wisconsin dans le michigan en
pennsylvanie en géorgie et dans le
nevada
si je pense que dans l'arizona mais la
raison en est toujours à compter donc
ils n'ont pas encore de procès ou de
poursuites en justice sur place mais ils
ont au minimum je crois c'est douze
mille voix de retard en géorgie ils ont
quarante mille voix de retard en
pennsylvanie ils en ont à peu près
autant dans le michigan
vingt mille environ dans le wisconsin ça
fait quand même beaucoup de bulletins ce
qui se passe actuellement c'est qu'ils
ont réussi à répertorier un certain
nombre on va pas dire de fraude mais au
loin d'irrégularités dans la procédure
mais pour l'instant elles portent pardon
sur quelques centaines de cas poids que
milliers de bulletins elle ne porte pas
sur les un nombre suffisant pour
inverser le résultat final dans ses
états c'est ça le problème pour eux
aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya environ cinq
millions de voix d'écart entre les deux
hommes ça fait beaucoup
dans ces conditions on peut se demander
quelle stratégie poursuit donald trump
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent
il cherche à prouver que de toute façon
l'élection lui aura été volé ça c'est
une sorte de point d'honneur pour lui
qu'il gagne qu'il ne gagne pas je pense
qu'il est ancré aujourd'hui dans
l'esprit des américains qu'il y a eu un
certain nombre de tricheries notamment
je pense dans l'état de pennsylvanie qui
est le plus pointés du doigt peut-être
le michigan-- également et donc l'idée
pour donald trump c'est de garder
vis-à-vis de sa base
ce sentiment que les
les démocrates étaient prêts à tout pour
remporter cette élection et qu'ils ont
en effet dans un certain nombre de cas
dépassé les bornes et qu'ils n'ont pas
hésité à procéder à un certain nombre
d'irrégularités et très souvent ce sont
des cas de harcèlement de représentants
républicains plus que des cas de fraude
ouverte mais il y a eu des tricheries un
vote invalides normalement net n'est pas
acceptable
maintenant encore une fois même si
certains des poursuites engagées par
donald trump sont couronnés de succès et
il a remporté une petite victoire encore
aujourd'hui il ya une cour de
pennsylvanie qui a reconnu que certains
bulletins arrivait en retard ne devait
pas être comptés donc de temps en temps
il marque des points
mais encore une fois ce sont des points
qui sont sur d'un décompte marginal et à
terme il est très peu probable qu'il
parvienne invalider le résultat qui est
celui reporté par les médias aujourd'hui
qu'elle devrait être à linverse
l'attitude des démocrates mais également
des médias américains des dirigeants
étrangers ce qu'il devrait dans ce
contexte s'abstenir par exemple de
féliciter joe biden ce qu'on devrait
attendre des résultats officiels et la
fin des recours judiciaires
absolument d'un point de vue d'un point
de vue juridique d'un point de vue
strictement légal d'un point de vue
strictement constitutionnel joe biden
n'est pas encore président je rappelle
une évidence les élections
présidentielles américaines se déroule
au suffrage indirect
c'est à dire que le 3 novembre dernier
et lorsque les électeurs américains ont
voté par courrier ils se sont contenté
d'envoyer un mandat à des grands
électeurs
ces grands électeurs se réuniront le 14
décembre le 14 décembre sera la date qui
officialisera le résultat et d'ici au 14
décembre
on s'attend à ce que toutes les
poursuites n'ont pas soit arrêté ou
suspendus mais qu'elle ait trouvé une
conclusion pour que le résultat a
indiqué par chaque état soit
incontestable est la preuve que le
président le président élu joe biden
n'est pas encore techniquement
présidence et que la constitution ne lui
applique pas encore les droits d'un
président élu et cela ne commencera qu'à
partir du 14 10
sambre après le vote du fameux collège
électoral donc d'ici là les démocrates
devraient faire preuve de patience
je pense qu'il devrait au contraire même
coopérer avec les républicains pour
chercher à faire toute la lumière et
rétablir une confiance de l'électorat
envers leurs institutions
quant aux dirigeants étrangers et
d'ailleurs certains l'ont bien compris
ils devraient s'abstenir je rappelle que
la chine et je pense là la russie à ce
jour n'ont pas encore officiellement
félicité jupp haydn ou kamala harris
en tout cas c'est pas ce qui se passe
parce que joe biden lui est en train de
monter son son équipe il a nommé chef de
cabinet ron klein savez quoi d'ailleurs
ont lancé
déjà beaucoup sur cet homme ça semble
saluer en tout cas cette nomination par
les démocrates
ron klein c'est un ancien de l'équipe
byden c'était sur son chief of staff son
chef de cabinet lorsqu'il était
vice-président est au tour de joe biden
on a surtout vu des gens qui ont
appartenu ou travailler avec l'équipe
obama et qui sont des fonctionnaires
assez chevronnés du département d'état
où d'ailleurs je pense à madame green
fils par exemple pour l'instant on a une
équipe obama bis qui se met en place
maintenant il est parfaitement naturel
que joe biden souhaite préparer et
mettre en place sa transition
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de contestation
lorsque le résultat est acceptée par
tout le monde
eh bien on peut commencer à travailler
avant que le collège électoral
n'officialise le résultat cette année
est un petit peu particulière parce que
d'une part le résultat est très serré
pas forcément
en ce qui concerne le vote populaire
mais au moins en ce qui concerne le
collège électoral
et comme il y à des contestations eh
bien il est logique que l'équipe de
transition attendent maintenant si joe
biden veut prendre les devants il peut
le faire mais techniquement légalement
juridiquement il ne sera pas élu avant
le 14 décembre
merci gérald ollivier journaliste franco
américain chercheur à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france